il est hypocrite de dire à ces
automobilistes qui ce kit qui vont
travailler avec leur voiture qu'à terme
on agit en leur faveur en les installant
dans l'essence à long terme parce que il
ya un moment difficile
on va essayer de trouver des
accompagnements mais le jour où ils vont
passer à l'électrique ou à des voitures
moins polluantes qui sont accompagnés
par par cette prime
eh bien ils vont sentir parce que c'est
les plus impactées dans leurs budgets et
enfin et enfin ça fait 40 ans non mais
c'est pour ça que c'est pas un vieux
truc se dépasser physiquement et dernier
point et dernier point il s'agit
maintenant d'installer une indépendance
par rapport au pétrole
ça suffit si vous voulez cette
dépendance de notre pays vous qui êtes
attachés à la souveraineté je le suis
aussi c'est une notion qui a été mise à
l'honneur ces jours ci eh bien nous
sommes il faut qu'on commence vous voyez
donc ce n'est pas du tout une petite
taxe une mesurette
il y a une vision derrière une vision
courageuse elle est portée par
l'écologie et par l'attention
enfin d'arriver à terme mais c'est ça la
politique de matignon et son courage ses
dettes dans le moyen terme je ne vous ai
pas sévir en cours